the country of india is one of the
largest countries in the world there's
1.4 billion people that want digital
decentralized assets and now the country
of india has capitulated and they are
going to legalize bitcoin and crypto
currencies what do i mean well what
we've seen in the past is that various
regulatory bodies and government
organizations in india they were
thinking about banning bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they were putting a lot
of pressure on the industry they were
actually cutting off those crypto
companies from the legacy banking system
but now they have reverse course the
people of india have spoken the people
of india told their government we want
bitcoin we want cryptocurrency there's a
lot of people on the ground that have
done some amazing work to make this
possible so what the hell exactly is
going on here we have the indian finance
minister nirmala sitharaman who noted
during recent remarks about this
specific move by the government she said
there has been a phenomenal increase in
transactions in virtual digital assets
the magnitude and frequency of these
transactions have made it imperative to
provide for a specific tax regime now
the key piece to this is they are not
going to ban bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they are going to
legalize it but they are going to add a
new tax remember how economic incentives
work if the government knows how to make
money on it they're going to encourage
that behavior and so the tax
specifically is a 30 tax on any income
from the transfer of digital assets all
crypto transactions will be taxed one
percent at the source of origination if
you gift virtual assets they'll be taxed
in the hands of the recipient and any
losses from the transfer of digital
assets can't be set off against any
other income now these are pretty
egregious taxation rules i don't
necessarily agree with them but it is
still important to understand that by
providing this regulatory oversight or
this taxation framework it means that
they can't make it illegal and so if
they're not going to make it illegal
they're going to tax the hell out of it
and that's exactly what they're doing
here we have a quote from sid hearth
who's the ceo of cerebral he said you
can't tax something which is illegal
hence this is a very positive move by
the government is very good for the
industry if there are tax clarities in
this space more money is likely to come
in now of course another question
becomes if the government of india is
going to make bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies legal they're going to
figure out how to make money on it by
taxing it what else are they going to do
well we know india is very interested in
creating a central bank digital currency
we've seen china start to create a pilot
and go ahead and move forward with their
plans we've seen the united states and
the federal reserve and politicians
within north america start talking about
central bank digital currencies but
india isn't going to be left behind on
that front either they're going to
introduce a digital rupee sometime
within the next year reportedly and
they've been testing its cbdc through a
number of controlled trials for several
months in the country and so now that
they actually have it built they have it
in pilot they are simply examining what
the impact on the banking and monetary
systems ultimately will be and so of
course if the government's going to get
in the game what are the entrepreneurs
and the operators on the ground saying
sumit from coindcx said the taxation of
virtual digital assets or crypto is a
step in the right direction gives
clarity around india's focus on digital
innovation promotion of blockchain is
welcome the details need to be studied
to comment further but it's great news
for crypto investors in india ultimately
the way that i look at this is the
government of india they were going to
be abrasive they were going to attack
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they were
going to cut off their citizens 1.4
billion people from participating in
this industry but the people of india
spoke they spoke loud and they spoke
frequently they were trending on twitter
over and over again and ultimately
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies are now
declaring victory in india the people of
india want bitcoin and crypto and now
they're going to get it their
government's going to make sure of it